court irvine will be on the mound 19
start your record could be much better
if uh had a little bit of support and
maybe some bullpen help but i think he's
up to the challenge he did give up a
home run to otani and here's ohtani now
with a chance to drive in a run
high fly ball mount to center field
ramon loriano's got it
fletcher goes to third out number two
and that'll bring up gosselin is in that
swing on a ground ball comebackers
speared by urban flipped to first in
time he does work out of it fletcher
left a third the angels failed to score
yeah get through the first inning and
the rest of it seems to be downhill
ohtani's first inning era is almost 10.
it is breezy the rest of the night so an
early test against him tonight
and the next payoff home
got him swinging
perfectly located heater on the outer
half
best pitch in baseball a fastball
outside corner at the knees no chance
for cannon 95 on top of that four seamer
here's the shortstop elvis andrews now
batting in the two hole tonight
2-2
past ohtani no problem you got a man
there
matt olson will be the next batter
challenging hitters conditions early
as olson takes a breaking ball into the
opposite field chasing goslin shy of the
track to retire the side
to mars up here now seems to get some
early runs against irvin
there it is
brandon marsha's first major league base
hit oh look at that in the dugout what a
great feeling that is for brandon
knowing what he's been through shohei
otani back to work against the middle of
the oakland lineup in the second lowry's
batting average up to 268 a far cry from
where we saw him last time these two
teams met
and the first pitch pop-up will make for
a quick out for rotani to start the
second
behind in the count of allman two
strikes to ohtani here's the pitch and
there's a swing and a miss he threw it
by him a fastball at 96. chugon with a
runner at second now for ramon lauriano
just one for his last 12. he got him
swinging wow looked like a slider right
there struck him out pair of strikeouts
for ohtani now mayfield bats
jack mayfield can't catch up to it and
that's the first strikeout here comes
ohtani a couple of home runs against the
a's this year smoked lorianna over he's
not going to get it goes past him picks
it up off the wall they're going to wave
home fletcher they have a play at the
plate the throw is there and he is out
so with two outs
fletcher running all the way and
he is execute the cutoff perfectly
murphy
puts the tag down and
the angels do not score how about that
big situation here with runners at
second and third and one gone elvis
andrews over his last 10.
he struck him out
nasty slider he's throwing two
unbelievable sliders tonight there
foul tip hung on by kurt suzuki and the
one to loriano and now he needs only
fade matt olson to keep it a scoreless
game and strand two runners in scoring
position
olson bounces it to the right side
fletcher is there to retire the side and
strand a pair it's coal earth
ohtani in a pitcher's duel they'll face
the switch hitter jed lowry then
moreland and chapman in a scoreless tie
and that time lowry knew he just got
under one eaton's got it and there's one
away in the fourth
and a ground ball for walsh here to make
for a quick out number two
here's the pitch and that's popped up on
the left side of the infield should be
the inning and the catch made by
iglesias the angel shortstop will wrap
things up suzuki will hold it first with
the lead off single and that'll bring up
iglesias as the angels have their fifth
hit
pop-up right side foul territory it's
playable for olson as he ambles over
toward the angels dug out and he makes
the catch
kevin's got a nice play he fires to
elvis anderson to first and that is a
double player
the bottom half for the fifth l'oreal
murphy and kemp here's the next pitch
and that's a one hopper nice stop there
by walsh the first baseman rushes to the
bag and gets there before the batter
sean murphy now he sent the fly ball to
center in his first at-bat 3-2 pitch got
him that's five for ohtani tonight two
gun bases empty now for tony kemp seven
in a row retired by ohtani since the
cannon doubled in the third 3-2 payoff
he got him swinging a slider struck him
out that's been the strikeout pitch for
rotating tonight and that will end the
inning it is the top of the sixth inning
angels nothing a's nothing
off the mound picks it up and fires in
time to get midfield shohei ohtani digs
in now
and he got him swinging kept it away at
all three pitches so tommy strikes out
they'll go back to work in the sixth
inning and face the top of the oakland
order in a scoreless game oh wow got him
that splitter was ridiculous that'll
make you smile as a pitcher i think he's
shook to get to that too yes he did yeah
he goes you know what i want to use that
unhittable pitch seven strikeouts for
him now here's andrews here's the pitch
there's a swing and a miss and down on
strikes again is
andrews ohtani now with
eight strikeouts he's
struck out the last four in a row and
he's retired the last ten in a row a
ball in his strike
two out runner at first in a scoreless
tie
back to shohei
that is how the inning went he is doing
everything tonight
to the seventh is still nothing nothing
the ends and the angels no gosselin to
lead it off here in the seventh inning
line drive toward the second baseman
perfectly positioned jed lowry shaded up
the middle snares the line drive knee
high and gosling is the first out jose
iglesias stands in
and he did it and is
finally swings and misses third
strikeout for cole irvin a scoreless tie
and shohei ohtani is done for the night
on the mound but we'll still see more of
him in the game because he's taking over
in right field making his fifth
appearance in right field this year
great opportunity for the ace
back to back walks nobody out brown at
second chapman at first
deep to left field
eden going back and
that baby's gone these were looking for
a hit with runners in scoring position
and boy did they get a big one
and a badly needed one is
ramon lauriana it looked like a hanging
slider seashell walks two and then gives
up a three-run homer you know makes his
first appearance since before the
all-star break
high in the air to left-center but it's
playable as ramon lauriano gets over
there and he makes the kick this is a
huge at-bat
fletcher line drive lowry's got it fires
to first not quite in time
but fletcher even scares this when he
makes it out two away and here's shohei
ohtani
popped up got him out in front chapman's
gonna move to his right
and that'll do it it's all hit nothing
else great job by lou gervino so claudio
comes in three nothing is and olson
that one down the right field
and that baby is gone a little left on
left changer from claudio
just hanging right in the middle
[Applause]
pack your bags baby all aboard next stop
pound town
sometimes just to walk a good back can
get things going you just never know the
engine has been pretty good as far as
putting pressure on the opponent and
late in the game
2-1 pitch
a shot up the line a three-hit night for
brandon marsh
gosselin wheeling around to score and
the angels are on the board with one out
in the ninth and that'll bring up adam
eaton first and third two out ninth
inning
foul territory
chapman over maybe
he
caught it
on a dead sprint
matt chapman caught it banged into the
side wall hung on and that's how the
game ends